le point aujourd'hui sur la situation
des bernaches du canada 2018 a été une
année très difficile pour l'espèce
alors peut-on s'attendre à voir moins de
bernaches dans le ciel
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
peu de villages profite d'une vue
spectaculaire sur le lac saint-pierre
que paie du febvre chagrin dans cette
municipalité et le témoin et nos des
plus beaux spectacles animaliers une
pays
la grande oie des neiges domine le ciel
dans l'espèce est abondante
parmi ces milliers d'oies se cache aussi
un autre grand migrateur la bernache du
canada fait également une halte à baie
du febvre mais en moins grand nombre
et cette année elle est encore plus
discret qu'à l'habitude
la bernache du canada revient d'une
année difficile une année qualifiée de
catastrophique par les biologistes
à
pour comprendre ce qui s'est passé il
faut se rendre dans le nord du québec là
où les bernaches migre chaque printemps
pour se reproduire
l'an dernier quand elle arrive sur leurs
sites de nidification loi de chemin 2018
une surprise de taille les attend
c'était gelé par tous les lacs étaient
gelés les rivières étaient encore joué
et c'est pas d'endroits propices pour
les oiseaux pour nicher
il ya des oiseaux qui sont l'eau y avait
des oiseaux encore mais ils nichent pas
parce qu'ils sont les deux oiseaux sont
ensemble sur la neige ou la glace fait
qu'il se tienne en coupe mais pour le
territoire en espérant que ça fond mais
sa part fondu et s'approfondit assez
vite pour leur permettre de nicher
jean rodrigue fait chaque printemps le
voyage vers le nord pour suivre la
reproduction de la bernache son travail
pour le service canadien de la faune
permet de fixer les quotas de chasse
annuelle regardez bien ces photos prises
par le biologiste à la même période de
l'année
celle ci représente un printemps
qualifiée de normale dans la toundra
celle-ci prise en 2018 montre l'état du
terrain à l'arrivée des bernaches le
contraste est frappant
jean rodrigue estime que seulement
quelques couples ont puni chez et élever
leurs couvées pour ces bernaches le rude
climat nordique a probablement été
impitoyables ils ont commencé un pompier
a couvé plv leur jeune talent menteur
que je m'aime pas certain que ces
oiseaux là il était assez fort pour
faire le voyage dans le sud faire la
migration dans le sud fait que c'est
pour moi c'est comme une année perdue
d'unification
la plupart des bernaches migrent vers le
nord au printemps
il existe bien une population de
bernaches résidente qui nichent dans le
sud mais elles restent peu nombreuses
la population de bernaches la plus
importante est celle de l'atlantique
c'est bernaches niche dans le nunavik
sur un immense territoire compris entre
la paix dutronc et la baie d'ungava
en tout on estime que cette population
compterait entre 700 et 800 mille
bernaches pour atténuer l'impact d'une
année de reproduction perdu les etats
unis ont déjà annoncé qu'il diminuerait
la durée de la chasse à la bernache le
canada pour sa part attend qu'on peut
voir ces règles pour bien comprendre que
66% des récoltes est fait aux états-unis
comparativement à 33 % à peu près au
canada fait que certains qui ont un
impact beaucoup plus important sur la
récolte que au canada
[Musique]
malgré une chasse écourtée aux états
unis mais biologiste sa tante 12 même à
voir apparaître un creux dans la courbe
démographique des bernaches du au
printemps en 2018
[Musique]
mais cet oiseau majestueux en a vu
d'autres ça fait des millénaires que la
bernache du canada évolue avec les
humeurs et les soubresauts du climat
arctique
avec un beau printemps ça peut être très
bien et facile parce que six oiseaux qui
vivent longtemps et qui peuvent se
reproduire sur plusieurs années donc
permettent à population de récupérer
rapidement surtout si on modifie les
règlements de chasse donc on augmente le
taux de survie des oiseaux et ça lui
permet de récupérer facilement
la météo n'a donc pas fini de forger la
résilience et les capacités d'adaptation
de ce grand migrateur
[Musique]
le tout dernier inventaire des
biologistes confirme que l'été 2010 9 a
été favorable aux bernaches les couples
ont donné naissance à un nombre plus
grand d'oisillons qu'à l'habitude
et comme ces jeunes étaient bien
portants on s'attend à ce que les
mortalités migratoire soit minime cette
année